[Music]
Zuri wants to know this is interesting
Desiree would Stef ever do Dancing with
the Stars we were so sad to see Derek
Fisher go home
someone needs to change the game for the
NBA pros uh I don't know I don't know if
he would make the decision to do it but
his mom really wants me to do it really
I think you should do it whatever so so
I don't know if I'm a lot of things but
I've been approached to do it and I just
I chickened out every single time
Wow you had some no Scott I've got two
left feet
really I've seen you're doing this on
Instagram you've got right now but
there's a difference between doing this
and doing a Foxtrot now well you are but
crack the whip you do these and time
start her CIL's do you think we could
ever see you maybe on Dancing with maybe
like down the road okay couple of years
it'd be a great the only motivator for
me and my mind is that like I would get
in phenomenal shape and that'd be a
great perk if you follow Aisha on
Instagram you already know that her
workouts are intimidating yeah inspired
this whole fitness transformation that
you've kind of gone through kid really
yeah and just realizing that like the
only thing that was gonna change the way
that I felt it's not even from a looks
standpoint it's from the inside out
right after a good workout you feel good
and then I'm able to you know enjoy all
this food that I love to bake so much
are you kind of hell-bent on a number
are you one of those people that's like
I gotta hit this number on the scale or
I can't I can't do that because I'm
built so differently like I've got I've
got thick skin and like I hold muscle so
doing the whole scale thing is just
never ieave shakur II sat down with ET
just days after her kitchenware
collection launched at Target the
cookware line helps support the no Kid
Hungry campaign I did keep people in
mind when I was thinking about products
so we don't so for instance my
mother-in-law stayed always come into my
house and take they're gonna go take
like my favorite coffee cup like this
and fill it with bacon grease and it
would fit by this stove and then it
would collect flies and then it was
unusable so we created a bacon
jar with a lid and this one's special
obviously because if they give back and
because it's in this shape and style and
color that highlights
[Music]